welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian chapter six the prisoner
okay the episode when mando and baby oda
gather a bunch of cameos by comedians
and star wars VIPs to trick them into
killing each other and thanks to privacy
comm for sponsoring this episode you
sign up now at privacy comm slash new
rock stars you can get $5 today to use
on any purchase online for free this
episode as usual is filled with
interesting Star Wars Easter eggs and
visual details so let's break them all
down
spoiler warning if you haven't seen the
episode yet let's get started mando
parks the razor Chris and a kind of
scrapyard groj operated by ran mandos
former colleague played by mark boon jr.
from sons of anarchy and Chris Nolan's
Batman Begins and there are actually a
few Nolan Batman parallels in this
episode that I'm not sure are
coincidental or intentional by director
Rick van Moo he WA like when they skip
around the cells in the New Republic
prison ship it looks like the shots of
Arkham and Batman Begins and mando
strobe-light attack on Mayfield it's the
same kind of sick effect the Batman used
in the sewers in The Dark Knight Rises
ran tells mando about a gig to rescue
one of their old crew members five
person job I got for now as we watch
this breakout it's obviously not a
five-person job Mayfield is a
sharpshooter zero is the guy in the van
Gian does knives no point do we see how
most of their skills are uniquely
required for this job Ocean's eleven
style because really this is all just a
con to screw over mando and they're
hoping the four of them plus Quinn will
be enough to take mando down that's the
real reason they don't let mando fly his
own ship and the real reason zero
doesn't give them a countdown upon
arrival and why they don't help him
later with the droids it's all designed
to keep mando off guard and how to
control the situation but surprise
surprise none of it works mandos armor
is both bhaskar and the plot variety so
we meet Mayfield played by comedian bill
burr one of the many
comedian cameos in the series former
imperial sharpshooter that's very much I
wasn't a stormtrooper wiseass solid joke
here about the notoriously bad aim of
the stormtroopers throughout the Star
Wars films Mayfield disses mando ship so
I can't do a bite slot machine he's
referring to the casino planet fin in
Bruges visited in the last Jedi I don't
really see the resemblance between the
razor crest in the slot machine but
whatever the next they meet Berg played
by Clancy Brown who voices Savage Opress
and other voices from the Clone Wars and
rebels Berg is a Deveraux knee in a red
skinned horn being one of whom we saw in
the Mos Eisley cantina and the first
star
so this is a Mandalorian I thought
they'd be Baker's this is kind of a
running joke in Star Wars with Leia and
Luke in the first film in with Innokin
and grievous and Revenge of the Sith
general grievous you're shorter than I
expected and then the droids name is
zero he's voiced by Richard Ayoade II
from the IT Crowd madam I am writing to
inform you of a fire which has broken
out of the premises of note that's too
formal my response time is quicker than
organics Sumatra caste move as DB Waller
bridge from fleabag Boise in L 337 and
soloist our story lastly there's Jeon a
Twilight woman in mandos former fling
played by natalya tina osha from game of
thrones and tongs from the Harry Potter
films she uses daggers and as every
troupe Star Wars fan knows elegant
daggers are famously crafted on the
Twilight planet Ryloth Ren explains why
they need mando ship because the razor
crest is off the old Imperial and the
New Republic grit it's a ghost so this
tells us that mando kept his ship out of
the hands of the Empire which seized and
or registered most of the vessels in the
galaxy when it took over everything and
like the non space Nazis of Earth the
Empire essentially made records of
everything but before we continue thanks
to privacy comm for sponsoring this
breakdown privacy tom is a free service
where you use these digital burner cards
whenever you shop online that way you
don't to use your real credit card info
so that way you inevitably decide to
sign your life away jus a streaming
content subscription and then you forget
you sign up for it and then they ding
yell with lightning-fast precision now
I've a system in place to protect your
forgetfulness privacy cards allow you to
control the limits on them so that you
can avoid and handing over the keys to
your finances every time you spend money
online so for example I've set up an
account with privacy and I link my bank
account and then I created this card
specifically for a monthly Netflix
subscription payment and for this
virtual card I'm gonna set the limit
just above the subscription amount that
way when I you know move on with my life
and I forget what I subscribe to it
can't Bing me for a second month that I
don't want in fact no vendor can
overcharge beyond the limit that you set
privacy will notify you that they
blocked it because the spending limit
was already reached see it's simple and
it's fast since just really one click
they also offer different plans there's
the free one that lets you create up to
12 cards a month but also a pro plan
where you can get 36 cards a month and
1% cash back on purchases and a team's
plan for small
distances just head to privacy calm /
new rock stars and sign up for an
account and as a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get five dollars to spin on your first
purchase for a limited time only hip
that's free money just go to privacy
comm / new rock stars to sign up now
it's interesting how they depict
hyperspace here with layers of grids
stacked in a red line tracking their
route from layer to layer if you think
of hyperspace is opening the rift in
space-time this reflects how wormholes
theoretically exist with space folded on
top of itself to allow entry points that
otherwise remote points in space the
crest jumps to hyperspace and the crew
gets to know each other a bit
well you flew with them Shia she as good
as they say ask him about the job on a
luck
Al's arc 3 is an outer rim planet from
these star wars video games and Mayfield
wonders what manda looks like under the
helmet maybe he's a gun good is that why
you so don't want to show your face and
with the disk to jar jar binks the lame
can't abide supply from the last Jedi
and the stormtroopers terrible aim bill
burr voices they common fan hates from
each of the three trilogies their fight
reveals baby oda
who Mayfield raps are you kidding me up
and they board the New Republic prison
ship the hatch opens in the same spiral
pattern that we've seen other star
warships do like the Falcon and Empire
and they use the comments comp links
that we've seen in many of the films
they passed the prison cells and one
contains a Nord inian the same species
as ryo Durant and solo which Mandalorian
showrunner Jon Favreau voiced another
contains some anonymous Imperial officer
which you can tell by his uniform Berg
shoots a mouse droid which lands them in
a firefight with a patrolling droids
commando takes them all out using his
many Inspector Gadget II in weapons
including the vibra blade that we saw
him with in episode 3 use that to slice
the droid at the kneecap in the control
room is a New Republic soldier with the
same egg-shaped helmet of the classic
rebel soldiers he's played by Matt
Lanter
who voices anakin in the animated series
and the Orbis lettering on his helmet
translates to DC one though some of the
letters are backwards maybe for the
Department of Corrections regiment 1 or
something mando tries to save him
despite him threatening to alert the New
Republic to their location with a
tracking beacon but Cheyenne kills him
so they find their prisoner Quinn played
by Ismael Cruz Cordova she aunts brother
Puma mandelip hind and past and now
they're trapping meadow to take Quinn's
place but
and Oh escapes returns to the control
room and traps them in a red lit
deathtrap evoke eing the imagery of the
deathtrap that Darth Vader trapped the
rebel soldiers in at the end of rogue
one mando defeats berg I crushed him
with the door and although it looks like
Perkin with stay in the first door made
it crushes him with the second door
calmly back his move from the pilot
episode and the way Luke beat the rancor
in Return of the Jedi and if you're
wondering how Berg survived that second
door and the prison cell later you can
see how the doors crushed they pointed
ends of his horns mando takes care of my
felled
Shion and zero shooting that droid at
the last second leaving baby oda
hilariously dumbfounded just like how
mando was mystified at the mud horn
stopping dead in its tracks in Episode
two thanks to baby Oda
now mando returns that favour and after
spending several episodes on the wrong
end of tracking beacons mando finally
turns the tables to weaponized a
tracking beacon leaving it like a
pinless grenade with Quinn when he
returns in two ran summoning it New
Republic explains all three pilots are
cameos by directors of past Mandalorian
episodes
our mandate Bologna plays trapper wolf
of course that's its name and then this
directors episode Rick family WA plays
jib Dodger which might be a joke about
like a jib crane on a film set maybe the
director hit his head on a crane at one
point and sash Kenner played by Deborah
Chow director of episode three and
showrunner of the upcoming obi-wan
series comment down below with your
favorite moment this episode follow me
on Instagram or Twitter at a boss and
subscribe to new rock stars or
breakdowns of everything you love thank
you for joining me
[Music]